and here are the nominees a little a
little weight
yep you just skipped a big chunk you did
good they just went it look it's
important that visual effects artists
are given the respect they deserve this
was a huge year for VF oh is that really
something you did you want to say I just
when they can just roll it back let's
just come what they want up let's just
give them the respect they deserve and
give them the damn award
okay come on
the Creed worlds and here the minds I'm
here other nominee right screw or
achievement in visual effects The Hobbit
an unexpected journey Jolla Terry Eric's
trained him David Clayton and our
Christopher white Life of Pi bill Weston
hopper the young rusher on Eric yonder
bore and Donald R Elliott Marvel's The
Avengers Yun Xers Jeff white guy
Williams and den suited
Prometheus Richard stammers Trevor would
Charlie Henley and Martin Hill Snow
White and the Huntsman Cedric Nicholas
Troy and Philip Brennan Neil corbelled
and Michael Dawson and the Oscar goes to
superheroes we can't even get on global
Life of Pi
the award for Theo
or Elliott it is
the the irony is not lost on any of us
up here that in a film whose central
premise is to ask the audience what they
believe is real or not real most of what
you see is well it's fake that's the
magical visual effects
I want to thank gillnetter and Elizabeth
Gabler and all those at Fox and Fox 2000
for realizing that sometimes it takes a
risk to make something special and Life
of Pi was a risk we're taking to our
director Angley you are inspiration and
you made an incredible journey for all
of us thank you to the David Woolmark
Mike Malone and Tommy Fisher for making
a wave tank the captain perhaps kept us
from having to go out to the real ocean
and John Kilkenny for inviting all of us
to the party in the first place to my
family for all the sacrifices they made
Gabriella love you so much my children
Christopher Thomas Howard Jenner and
Samantha thank you for inspiring me
every day my mom and dad think for time
we could do any crazy career choice I
wanted finally I want to thank all the
artists work in this film for over a
year including Rhythm & Hues
sadly Rhythm & Hues is sufferings severe
financial difficulties right now it I
heard you all remember